uh terry says andrew how much
conversation and time needed to be spent
on wife ltr i know you've mentioned all
you do is work party come out have sex
and sleep how do you bond with your
women if that's at all
yeah of course of course i bond with my
woman i want to make something clear a
lot of people have this mis
understanding about me that i live a
loveless life and my girls are just
scared of me etc my relationships at
home look pretty much like any other
loving happy relationship my women love
me and i love them and we're nice to
each other and we are bonded by
common drive towards my goals because
i'm the man and i'm trying to conquer
the world so she finds her bonding with
me in her mutual interest in my success
when genghis khan was conquering the
earth do you think he had to come home
and talk knitting with a [ __ ] or did he
come home and talk about the fact he
conquered the earth
that's what she was like oh well i'm
with genghis oh oh you murdered people
today okay genghis good job so like you
want to bond with your wife you to come
home with a story to tell you need some
conquest you're probably not doing [ __ ]
you're coming home with nothing to
[ __ ] talk about that's your fault
ain't her fault that's your problem if
you were doing enough interesting then
you'd be bonded fine trust me i could
come in the house give a three second
rendition rendition of my day and the
problems i've solved and the bullets
i've dodged and then it's on
like th
that's that's about being a man too many
too many people in this space
think
they think they need to go to the woman
and change the woman i promise you if
you're actually the man it ain't that
hard it really isn't
yep it's been said many times women
would rather share a high value alpha
than be straddled with a faithful loser
uh enrique who's also a fighter by the
way he's an up-and-comer i've i've
talked to him a few times says uh shows
the power and value of uh networking
thank you for all your resources
gentlemen you're welcome dude i'm sure
andrews but this is it right you need to
know who's worth knowing i know if i
need i know if i needed some information
in canada and i would say to rich look
rich this this this this could you help
me out he'd help me out if he had
something go down in eastern europe he'd
say look this has happened in in hungary
or romania what do you got on the guy 20
minutes boom done you need to know
important people and you're only going
to know important people life's a value
exchange right you're going to get value
from people when you can give value to
people and if you're going through life
and you don't know anybody important
it's probably because you're not very
important yourself and and that's it's
all once again completely your fault i
truly believe not to get too spiritual
to preach too much but i truly believe
the life that even every single one of
us lives is the life that we have
accepted and constructed for ourselves
you are living a life that is completely
head to toe your fault if you wanted to
be better you'd be more uncomfortable
with what you currently have to get it
to the point where it would need to be
it's all your fault if you're sitting
there going oh you know my wife's a
three i play tekken on twitch for
pennies my name's ryan stone your life
sucks
dude stop picking up stop picking on
ryan
there's no one else
right
you have to accept it
all right let's
let's get off the ryan thing
you